>> SAUER: Hi, I'm Fred Sauer with Developer
Advocate. And I'm here today with three guys
with an idea. And they'd like to share this
idea with you and talk a little bit about
their application. If you guys can introduce
yourselves.
>> RANGNEKAR: Hi, I'm Vikram.
>> GUANG: Iím Ming.
>> KUMAR: I'm Naveen.
>> GUANG: And we are from Socialwok
>> SAUER: Can you guys maybe talk about some
of your motivations for building Socialwok?
>> RANGNEKAR: Well, the motivation for building
Socialwok really came from the fact that we
spend so much time on tools like Facebook,
FriendFeed. And that concept of "passive sharing"
is really great because that helps me communicate
with my friends without really emailing anyone.
I barely know their emails anymore. And then
I'm back at work and, you know, I tend to
CC people, BCC people. And so, I've had bringing--that's
when I got kind of evolved from. We decided
that bringing that kind of passive sharing
model to business collaboration would reduce
a lot of mails that are floating around inside
the organization. And Goggle Apps seems to
be the best collaborative platform for businesses.
And so, we decided that it's a natural fit
to add our passive sharing model, to add social
walk directly into Goggle Apps.
SAUER: Okay. Can you maybe talk about some
of the other enablers you mentioned, Google
Apps. What is it that allowed you to kind
of build this platform out and bring this
idea to fruition?
>> KUMAR: Well, it all starts with Google
App Engine. Basically with Google App Engine,
we don't have to think about how we're going
to scale our application. You don't have to
build. You don't have to own a farm of servers
in the data center. We basically just develop,
deploy and almost forget about it. And all
we have to do is worry about developing our
App the best we can and making sure that it's
working on that side. From there, you know,
we basically got--we move to the front end
which is GWT. And the cool thing about GWT
is that it's also in Java. We're using App
Engine with the Java language support. And
for us basically, we're developing now end
to end in the Java programming language. And
so, we really are more efficient, we don't
have to think about how we switch between
different languages. It makes it very, very
efficient for us to develop new features.
And then from there, you know, we're using
the Google data APIs, which allow us to integrate
pretty deeply into Google Apps. And so the
Google data APIs basically are a great set
of tools that allow us to sort of fit into
Google Apps and make our application more
like a Google App.
>> GUANG: And I just want to add that actually
using Google App Engine Java, using GWT, and
Google data APIs enable us to create a very
full blown enterprise grade, App Engine Java
application, right, with very little cost.
>> SAUER: Why did you choose to integrate
so tightly with Google Apps? Was it the APIs
or what else was of interest to you?
>> GUANG: I think the key point with Google
Apps is that as Vikram has mentioned, right?
In this wall right now we see that Google
Apps is one of the foremost growing online
call based office productivity tools, right?
A lot of people are starting to switch towards
that direction, right? Especially small and
medium businesses and that is what Socialwok
is trying to target, right? And so, we have
these people using all this online tools.
And so, we're basically the social layer on
top. And it's all powered by the clock, right?
From using Google tools, App Engine Java,
and GWT, the whole works. The whole stack.
>> RANGNEKAR: It just makes sense because
it's almost a no-brainer to choose Google
Apps as our distribution.
>> SAUER: Was this--is this true for Google
Wave Toolkit and App Engine? Had you started
with those tools from the beginning or did
you experiment in other places and changed
your mind later down the road?
>> KUMAR: When we started, of course, we started
playing around with standard Java, Java Enterprise
Stacks, Standard GWT and we basically started
developing from there. And then we saw that,
you know, this Google App Engine, we've heard
about it before but it was all piped on. But
then they said, "You know, we're announcing
Java language support." And so, we thought,
"You know, why not actually do this, you know,
let's not worry about having to find a bunch
of servers. Let's actually, you know, make
our App work on Google App Engine." And so,
from that discussion it's pretty easy for
us to move our App to Google App Engine. And
then with GWT, we had already started writing
an interface that was based with HTML, JavaScript.
We used the Dojo Toolkit initially and it
worked well. But we ran into some issues basically
with speed and performance or application.
And, you know, since we wanted to integrate
more with Google we feel that, you know, performance
is key. And so, one of the things that we
decide to do was look at Google Web Toolkit
because we heard great stories about how the
performance was very good. And so, we used
that to actually--we started to redevelop
in that end. For us, it was a little awkward
at first because, you know, you're not used
to writing interfaces in Java, especially
web interfaces. But once we kind of got into
it, we were able to develop and we became
much more efficient as the process went on.
RANGNEKAR: I'd like to add that the biggest
problem we've had using Dojo or any of the
other toolkits was browser compatibility.
And so, we spent a significant amount of time
trying to get it to work on other older browsers.
And so, and we decided those aren't worth
our time. It was a distraction and GWT just
allowed us to work on everything from an iphone
to IE8, to Chrome, to Safari Webkit. It was
amazing. And so, I mean we, you know, that
actually saved us a ton of time.
>> SAUER: And so, that sounds pretty interesting.
What would you say is the most compelling
feature you were able to build up because
you were under the Web Toolkit and App Engine
and didn't have to spend your time building
servers or wrangling cross browser issues.
What did you use that time for and do you
have maybe a story for us?
>> GUANG: And so, I think one of the most
compelling things for us ix that you can see,
right? We have a whole feed phase service.
And so, you can see all these things where
the feeds are but the most exciting part is
we went from Web to Mobile Web, right? We
have it on iphone, and the Android. And we
were able to do all of these very, very quickly
with very minimal cost. I think that's a big
win for developers, right? The ability to
create a web service that is highly scalable
with download and more importantly you can
pop it out of platforms very quickly and deal
with all these browsing compatibility issues
that what Vikram has mentioned. And so, that
is I will say one of the very important values
for us using GWT.
>> SAUER: That's very cool.
>> RANGNEKAR: Our application of App 2, we
also have that rock solid feel of the web
interface that's kind of important today that
a lot of Google applications like Reader and
a few of the other ones actually, you know,
in part you feel like this is a solid product
that you're dealing with, so. And so, GWT
actually brings that, your partner for that
level.
>> SAUER: Would you have any advice to share
with other developers that are likely looking
to build an application maybe on a similar
stack or have other ideas that they'd like
to implement?
>> GUANG: I think that most important thing
is that, you know, you should try our call.google.com,
right? All the projects are there. And also
Google has been very friendly in the sense
that there are IRC chats installed. And so,
at times we hooked up with some of the developers
from IRC channels. And so, I highly encourage
people to join some of the impromptu IRC chats
that are from the App Engine team, right,
where developer members like Jason Cooper,
Max Ross and the other guys are on. And so,
that's a very good place. And also your Google,
oh, sorry, call.google.com also has forms
where developers have posted their questions.
And so, we have done that too.
>> SAUER: And so, you really took advantage
of the community and were able to collaborate
with others?
>> GUANG: Yeah, I think that's very important.
And I think we also looked at other implementation
for other companies and we find that Google
has the most, in our view, the most developer
friendly, right, form of open source perspective
as well as answering questions and having
a whole knowledge base for developers to look
into.
>> RANGNEKAR: However the most important thing
is developers getting the platform is to make
sure that, you know, you donít spend a
considerable amount of time just, you know,
searching for answers if you know where to
find them. There should be proper documentation
and most of the tools, all the tools in fact
we worked with including that of API, GWT,
App Engine Java was documented. And the documentation
was improving. And so, that actually helped
us through. You know, we didn't have to go
and search obscure forums for information
because it's all in one place and that gave
us a lot of speed.
>> KUMAR: And I guess the final piece of advice
that we give to any developer is to just dive
in, you know. Google doesn't provide, doesn't,
you know, bar you from anything, you know.
App Engine has free quarters that let you
get started. You can easily just write your
first App, deploy it and actually just get
started. And when you--once you dive in then
it becomes really easy to sort of push ahead
and actually innovate much more.
>> GUANG: Just to add to the committee angle
of what Fred mentioned, right. Also as for
us we are from Singapore. We actually helped
set up the Singapore GTUG, the G-Tech. And
around the world there's many G-Techs, right?
And we found that when we hosted the first
G-Tech for Singapore on App Engine and GWT,
we had 150 people showed up. And they gave
us a lot of feedback. And so, I highly encourage
developers, right, if you are in wherever
you are, Moscow, Tokyo, China, I understand
that there are G-Techs in all of these place,
you should go talk to other developers. And
also, more importantly, do something first
and then show it to other people and get feedback.
>> RANGNEKAR: Yes, absolutely. I think to
add to the advantages of App Engines something
that just occurred to me was the fact that,
you know, this is the advice I give to a lot
of developers, don't spend time being system
administrators, you know. I know it's fun
to roll your own stuff but it doesn't always
work in production or you spend a lot of time
doing stuff that as a developer you should
not maybe be looking at. And so, App Engine,
you know, as opposed to a lot of other App
platforms lets you be a developer and not
a system administrator. And so, you know,
so you can actually have a code deployed and
running, you know, from the second you get
on it. And so, that's really cool.
>> SAUER: That's great. And so, do you have
maybe any parting advice for Google? What
is it that we can do to better help developers
like you and make you more productive?
>> GUANG: I think from our perspective the
only chance we had was evolvement. It would
be great if we could get more visibility from
Google regarding the features launch and also
I think the IRC channels are a good start
to get real live interaction but more visibility
would be great.
>> SAUER: Okay. Well, thank you very much.
Thank you for coming and sharing your idea
with us.
>> RANGNEKAR: Thank you.
>> GUANG: Thank you.
>> SAUER: Okay.